now it's time for WTF otherwise known as
what the failure join me now Jimmy Fila
host of fox Across America hi Jimmy how
are you good to see you better now um
we've heard we've heard that people call
Kamala Harris
I guess a lot of different things but
this one's new watch this
the best example is why voting matters
is because you have vice president
Harris some people refer to some people
say Madam vice president but around the
White House we call it the MVP
listen they call her MVP the way you
call a stupid person Einstein like oh
you locked your keys in the car nice
going Einstein That's Why They Call Her
MVP oh you cackled about the Border
again nice going MVP there's no other
reason to call her this Kamala Harris is
so dumb she studied for a covid test
okay nobody believes she's the MVP save
for the fact that if it weren't for her
incompetence Biden would have been hit
with the 25th Amendment like a year and
a half ago that's her contribution to
this Administration
Jimmy they're they're as terrified of
her almost as they are of trump winning
right all right
they're freaking out and she's gone
through staff like yeah you know what
through a goose as my uncle used to say
well said yes they want no part of this
if she was yeah go ahead yeah Jimmy yeah
Jimmy this broke late tonight
um and I know this pains you but Joe
Biden's dog Commander just bit another
secret service agent now this is
reportedly I guess the 11th time this
has happened I've heard of the one bite
rule Jimmy isn't there like a one bite
or two bite rule but now just like
everything else there's inflation with
the bites so I guess 11 really means one
yeah to be clear in the Biden White
House
you know I have two theories here Laura
you know what there's one of the
theories dogs have really strong noses
and there's so much cocaine in this
White House these dogs might just be
hyped up that could be number one number
two is the dog could be confused he sees
Joe sniffing people all the time and
goes oh wait maybe I'm the human doing
Secret Service protection I have to
attack anybody who comes near the
president I don't know what's going on
in this white house it's a bizarre thing
to watch but I still enjoy having the
dogs there if only because it's nice to
see someone making deals under the table
besides Hunter there you go
I mean was it you who said this I'm not
sure they're going to change they're
going to hope for a change in behavior
of the dog and they're going to go from
calling it Commander to did you
hear that so that's silly come on
yeah all right a new Daily Mail poll
just released today voters were asked if
aliens attack Earth do you think would
be safer oh this is ridiculous under Joe
Biden or Donald Trump okay 43 Jimmy said
Trump 32 of brain dead people said Biden
and 25 said they didn't know they
thought they were talking about illegal
aliens or something I don't know Jimmy
what would your answer be well that's
why this is easy because Trump is going
to flatter the aliens into making peace
because he's going to brag that only the
best aliens come under his
administration the guy get the best
aliens all the best aliens want to come
to earth when I'm here Biden is going to
ask for their pronouns and they're going
to Nuke us either that or he's going to
give them stimulus checks on a cell
phone and stick them in a suite at The
Roosevelt Hotel at which point they're
not going to like the accommodations and
they're going to Nuke us so I am
definitely all the way with Trump on
this one there's no way it ends good
under Biden
all right Jimmy I know you and I are
scheduled to do what we're going to do a
lot of speeches together right appearing
together and we're going to do this you
didn't know about that okay I've already
arranged it I've already arranged the
whole thing there's like a big demand
for us but the Daily Mail is reporting
that we have some competition out there
because Michelle Obama got paid 741
000 for a one-hour speech
an event one hour in Germany this week
according to the uh events Instagram
post her speech was focused Jimmy on
encouraging our audience to embrace
their unique strengths push past
self-doubt and highlight the importance
of diversity and for that she got
741 thousand dollars
stop it now really quickly it is
Oktoberfest so these people might be
drunk right now I just love that the
woman who took away snacks from school
kids is making money at the hot pretzel
convention bits and pretzels like what a
sellout
but listen oh let's move yeah but
nothing for nothing I mean her husband
is running the country right now so it's
a pretty good price tag when you
consider she's the behind the scenes
first lady
well she's the most sought after speaker
one of the most sought after speakers in
the world
so I mean look it's a good gig I mean
you like the free enterprise system it's
a good Gig if you can get it I mean yeah
that's called capitalism I wish the
Obama supported it for everybody else
that's the problem all right Jimmy we'll
see we'll see if we can get like half of
that okay it might a quarter maybe maybe
a hundredth of that okay Jimmy we'll see
if we can get that
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else